Kaitlin and I are super fans.
The second season of HBO
hit show The White Lotus.
Sorry, I won't make it.
Or if you're just speaking the t
It was a close last night.
And we have to warn you,
because we're going to
this is a spoiler alert.
So if you don't want to know
what happened,
I would say turn the volume down
We don't want you to change the
I'll just turn the volume down.
So fans
have spent the entire season the
and trying to figure out one que
who was that floating body?
They finally got their answer.
It was last night
You've had very bad luck
Best thing about Rocky is
I can always change
Italy's just so romantic.
You're going to die.
Okay, who's going to die?
I will Sharpe's here.
He plays the night Lotus.
And we should note that HBO is t
It's a parent company to CNN.
Okay, so I want to brother Disco
Wait a minute.
What about Discovery?
We're in the same company.
Let's get some distant cousins.
So thank you for joining us.
You said.
I know that you thought
that you predicted.
You've been telling everybody
that things are going to get mes
You said fans should expect fire
and there were fireworks.
I have to say, I was wrong.
This is a spoiler alert
and take closure is
I thought that you were the kill
I did.
Okay.
I think that's fair.
And, I mean,
I don't know what kind
of conversations Mike
had with the rest of the cast.
I remember,
you know, him
being very upfront with me
towards the beginning
about how he did want Ethan to b
a kind of enigma,
you know,
especially towards
the beginning of the series.
And for it to be like an availab
that maybe he is going to be the
So I guess I was mindful of that
in the playing of it,
whilst also having an eye on
the long game of how really play
So you started the show
and the cast does not know
who the killer is or who dies.
No, we did.
We did. We had all seven scripts
and so
yeah, we've been
carrying those secrets for a whi
I guess.
And so in
a way, it's
a relief
to be able to talk about it
more freely now.
But yeah. Wow, what?
What a bold move on my part.
Am I missing something
or I still don't know who the ki
So. But I don't know if we shoul
I don't think we should think
we should say who the killer is.
So we're not spoil it.
Turn the volume
is kind of a spoiler alert, but
But
the twist is,
is that the
kit's a double thing
because the killer ends up
being something else as well,
which I won't say yes. Right.
So this there's a
there's a sort of, you know,
double twist here.
Yes.
Yeah. Yes.
And I think, you know,
that's part of the beauty of it
is that it plays out in a kind o
complicated, tragicomic way.
And it's kind of playful and bom
but also,
you know, sad and poignant as we
And I think yeah.
As I say,
I just think it's a very courage
move on my part and to go there.
And it's one of the things
I really admire about I'm sorry
if you haven't watched this show
What's so fascinating
is it's kind of this idea,
like they're in these amazing se
and it's like people
go to paradise,
but they still take their proble
with them.
Like it's
talk about privilege about class
about sex and all of that.
I wonder what you thought of
just like the themes
for this season,
because I know
Mike White says
it wasn't what he initially thou
it was going to be.
And he changed it based on the s
Yeah.
So, I
mean, I
definitely think this season
explores, you know, sexual polit
and gender politics, too.
I think the different
ways in which men and women hist
can behave for better or worse.
And as you say,
I think it's the Sicilians
that think that informs a lot of
And I remember him
saying to me
that one of the first
inspirations
for the story of this season was
when he asked a local
about the test anymore.
You know, there's sculptures of
that you see
often in the show
and that Ethan and Harper
have one in that.
I said,
and the story
that is relayed in the show is,
is the actual backstory for the
So, yeah, I think I think
it's it's a dark series,
I think in a funny way.
It's also romantic I think might
and pieces of light in that
and he explores
the nature of relationships.
But you know,
without shying away
from all the gnarliest, messiest
complex places their relationshi
take, you